bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france sans surprise il faudra donc
attendre 20 heures ce soir pour être
fixé sur les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires on l'a vu aucune annonce à
l'issue du conseil des ministres et
pourtant l'idée d'en reconfigurer dans
toutes les têtes aujourd'hui est ce que
l'exécutif préparent les esprits depuis
hier oh oui même depuis plusieurs jours
on sent bien qu'il ya une communication
de suggestions un hadj comme diraient
les anglo saxons tour tout simplement
préparer l'opinion publique à un
durcissement des contraintes sanitaires
alors maintenant la question qui se pose
c'est de savoir quelle forme prendra ce
confinement
on voit bien que actuellement on lance
un certain nombre de sonde en direction
des médias et de l'opinion en parlant
d'un confinement qui ne serait pas tout
à fait le même que celui du printemps
dernier avec la possibilité de laisser
mourir de laisser les écoles entre
autres ouverte voire à certain nombre de
services publics également ouvert on
attend bien évidemment jour de 16 ce
soir du côté de la république qui
précise et surtout qui finalement d'un
plan d'ensemble qui soit cohérent parce
que head et diablement ce qui a manqué
le plus depuis la sortie du confinement
dix ans cette période qui est allée du
mois de mai de la fin mais jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est vraisemblablement une
absence de cohérence dans les mesures
qui ont été proposées je prendrai un
seul exemple par exemple qui est
l'exemple de la fermeture des bars la
fermeture des restaurants dans un
certain nombre de métropoles et le
maintien par exemple des transports en
commun on voit bien que ce type de
mesure à paris d'une certaine manière
assez contradictoire pour une grande
partie de nos concitoyens
est-ce que selon vous les décisions sont
désormais actés après le conseil des
ministres après en deuxième conseil de
défense en 24 heures
ou alors les choses peuvent encore
évoluer il faudra vraiment attendre le
tout dernier moment pour qu emmanuel
macron soit sûr de sa décision puisque
vous le disiez cette idée dur
confinement on l'entend depuis plusieurs
heures plusieurs jours et ce que les
réactions qui en découlent aujourd'hui
dans la presse sur les plateaux télé
peut encore influer le chef de l'état
oui il est clair que on a le sentiment
qu'il y a un pouvoir qui quand même pour
l'instant flotte dans la façon dont il
faut gérer ce rebond épidémique alors
l'argument de défense si je puis dire
aujourd'hui de l'exécutif c'est de dire
que finalement nous ne sont pas les
seuls dans cette situation ce qui est
vrai en partie on voit que l'épidémie
aujourd'hui rebondi chez un certain
nombre de nos voisins européens mais
vraisemblablement de manière pour
l'instant en tout cas au niveau du taux
d'incidence beaucoup moins forte et même
au niveau du taux de l'amour table du
taux de mortalité puisque hier nous
avons quand même eu un chiffre de je
crois 527 tous à 135 130 décès liés à la
halak au vide
est-ce que cet argument finalement de
comparaison avec les autres pays
européens était un argument qui suffira
à 10 ans d'une manière éteindre les
controverses je ne le crois pas parce
que signalement ce qui se passe depuis
le début de cette crise c'est à dire
depuis le printemps
c'est que il ya une forme de péché
originel qui pèsent sur l'action de
l'exécutif c'est à la fois d'être
insuffisamment réactif de ne pas avoir
réglé le problème des moyens sanitaires
et on voit qu'il ya déjà des
controverses et des polémiques sur la
question notamment hors des lits de
réanimation et notamment des moyens
humains pour permettre au système
hospitalier de tenir face à ce choc de
la seconde de ce que l'on peut appeler
aujourd'hui la seconde vague bio
troisième point c'est la question de la
coordination des services
il ya un rapport qui vient de fuiter
manifestement dans la presse ce matin
dans le canard enchaîné pour ne pas le
nommer qui montre que l'absence de
coordination de l'ensemble du système
sanitaire
aggravé la crise donc évidemment sur ces
trois sujets la réactivité les moyens
l'organisation est ce qu'il y avait un
véritable retour d'expérience de la part
de l'exécutif en france c'est une
question qui ne cessent de se poser et
qui empoisonnent fortement à la fois
l'action et la communication de
l'exécutif
quelle devrait être la posture des
manuels macron ce soir l'enjeu pour lui
et aussi l'adhésion des français parce
que vous parlez de l'europe on voit en
italie notamment une partie de la
population descend dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour protester contre les
restrictions il faudra qu'ils soient
claires sur les mesures c'est à dire
qu'il faudra qui donne de la cohérence
au dispositif qui le compte mettre en
place pour aujourd'hui contrôler
l'épidémie il faudra qu'il soit clair
sur les moyens notamment qu'il entend
mettre en place pour mettre un terme à
cette épidémie et il faudra surtout que
il est vite je pense de considérer que
comme c'est une petite musique que l'on
entend parfois de la part des autorités
politiques mais des autorités sanitaires
que ce sont disons le comportement des
françaises et des français qui serait
responsable de cette deuxième flambé en
l'occurrence je crois que tout disent
tout discours infantilisant aujourd'hui
est un discours qu'il sera de moins en
moins acceptée pour deux raisons parce
que d'abord tout simplement le virus
continue à circuler de manière active
que la question des moyens encore une
fois n'a pas été réglé et que la société
considère quand même que in fine et
c'est à l'état de la protéger sur le
plan sanitaire et qu' elle s'est plutôt
dans le fond et sur la durée à s'est
bien comportée ont regardé consignes qui
ont été émises par les différentes
autorités qu'elles soient autorités
politiques autorités sanitaires donc de
l'incohérent oh là là non on alors un
petit problème de son arnaud benedetti
un tout petit mot assez rapidement
les mesures qui seront annoncées ce soir
ces mesures est bien le parlement aura
l'occasion d'en débattre et de voter
demain puisque un débat se tiendra le
matin l'assemblée et l'après midi au
sénat quel poids pèse aujourd'hui les
parlementaires
dans ce contexte de durcissement des
mesures sanitaires en un mot s'il vous
plaît parce que le temps nous manque
or rapidement ils font entendre comme
ils l'ont fait lors de leur rencontre
avec jean castex vraisemblablement leurs
interprétations divergent pour ce qui
concerne nos positions de la façon dont
est géré cette épidémie mais de toutes
façons de toute évidence le président de
la république et son gouvernement au
rang le soutien de la majorité
parlementaire pour mettre en place des
nouvelles mesures
merci beaucoup au bénin des ide avaient
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire